हेलो एवरीवन वेरी गुड इवनिंग तू जो
वेलकम
ओके एक मिनट और वेट करते हैं
कम कर दीजिए आप लोग अपने लोकल ग्रुप में
लाइव क्लास का नोटिफिकेशन दाल दीजिए
युटुब के युटुब चैनल युटुब चैनल
का लिंक मिलेगा वहां पर जाकर हमारा ऑप्शन
है उधर जाकर आपको क्या करना है जैसे ही आप
की क्लास खत्म हो जाएगी डेट की उसके बाद
जाइए उधर जो भी आपने शिखा कमेंट आउट कीजिए
सबको पता है मैं एक बार आपको फिर से बता
देता हूं
यहां से लंदन के पेज पर जाइए
आपको क्या करना वहां जान के बाद कमेंट में
अपने कमेंट प्रोवाइड कीजिए जो भी आपने
शिखा इस क्लास में
प्रोडक्ट की दूसरों को पता चले की इस डेट
में क्या कम हुआ था क्या सिखाया गया था आप
लोगों को
ठीक है
ज्यादा कोई आएगा नहीं
तो आज का टॉपिक रहेगा
तो आपको बता चुका हूं एक जो एक फाइल होती
है शैडो फाइल पासवर्ड
मैनेजमेंट कैसे करते उसके बड़े में
बताऊंगा उससे पहले कुछ एक इंपॉर्टेंट
कॉन्सेप्ट है दोनों इंपॉर्टेंट कॉन्सेप्ट
उसके बड़े में डिस्कस करते हैं
तो स्टार्ट करते हैं
कैसे मेंटेन करते हैं
है तो देखो जैसे अगर आपको कोई ऐसा कोई
टास्क परफॉर्म करना है जिसको कोई एडमिन या
रोटी कर सकता है वह कैसे कर सकते हो तो वह
कैसे कर सकते हो तो आपको पता है की सिंपली
हम क्या करेंगे की नॉर्मल यूजर को
प्रिविलेज होते ही नहीं है तो मैं रूट
यूजर बनेगा और उसके बाद वो उस्ताद को
पकाकॉम करने की कोशिश करूंगा अब जैसे की
मेरा एक यूजर है इसमें
तो मैं क्या करता हूं स्विच करने को कुछ
पता हूं स्विच और आज परमानेंट दे फ्रॉम
नेक्स्ट और इंटर कर देता हूं उसके बाद में
पासवर्ड इसके अंदर डालता हूं और क्या
मेरा क्या है बेस्ट सेल की वजह से सेल कुछ
शो कर रहा है अगर मैं पीडी हुए मैं करके
दिखता हूं तो आपको पता चल जाएगा मी तो
आपको पता है इसका तो अब हम क्या करते हैं
की हम एक यूजर एड करना है
तो मैं सिंपली क्या करता हूं यूजर और आपको
पता है कैसे करते हैं कमांड उसके बाद में
एक नाम सचिन नाम से करना चाहता हूं सिंपली
ओके ये ऑलरेडी दिखा रहा है ओके ओके
[संगीत]
ट्राई अगेन लेटर
इंग्लिश के खाने का मतलब यहां पर यह है की
इस वीडियो को परमिशन नहीं है की यह नॉर्मल
अकाउंट है और इसको परमिशन नहीं है रूट
वाले कम करने की
कम कर सकता है वो कम ये कर नहीं सकता अब
क्या होता है की नॉर्मल यूजर को वह सारे
कम करने की परमिशन नहीं होती है जो कोई भी
रोटी एडमिन कर सकता है उसके लिए वो कैसे
कर सकते हैं उसका एक छोटा सा कॉन्सेप्ट है
उसको बताने की मैं कोशिश करता हूं अब क्या
होता है की जितनी भी बढ़िया ऑर्गेनाइजेशन
होती हैं सबके अंदर जितने भी बड़े
ऑर्गेनाइजेशन होती है उनके अंदर क्या है
लिमिटेड लोगों को यही रूट का यह सुपर यूजर
का एक्सेस होता है जनरली रोड का पासवर्ड
क्या होता है की एक डिजिटल टूल होता है
उसके अंदर रखा जाता है और उसमें क्या होता
है की रोड का जो पासवर्ड है कंटीन्यूअस
लगातार चेंज हो रहा होता है एक पर्टिकुलर
टाइम के बाद 15 डेज 20 डेज 30 डेज के बाद
या क्या होता है
लेकिन दोनों ही कैसे में क्या होता है की
पासवर्ड को लेने के लिए आपको रीजन बताना
पड़ता है रिक्वेस्ट करना पड़ता है लेकिन
ब्यूटी सिक्योरिटी रीजन जो रूट पासवर्ड
कभी किसी के साथ शेर नहीं किया जाता इस
कैसे में क्या होता है की यूजर कनॉट लॉगिन
तू डी सिस्टम
कर नहीं सकते क्योंकि अगर आपको स्विच करना
है उसके लिए स कमांड का उसे करना पड़ेगा स
कमांड उसे ली होगी क्योंकि आपके पास रोड
का पासवर्ड नहीं है अब क्या होता है ये सब
करने के लिए जब हमारे पास का पासवर्ड नहीं
है तो
नॉर्मल क्या रूट का पासवर्ड कैसे शेर किया
नहीं जा सकता तो उसके लिए इस कैसे में एक
टूल का उसे किया जाता है
जिसका नाम होता है
इसका मतलब होता है
तो बन सकते हैं उसके लिए हमारे पास यूजर
नाम
सुडो नॉर्मली उसके पास क्या होता है जब भी
आप छोड़ो को उसे करते हैं नॉर्मली क्या
होता है की एक यूजर जो पासवर्ड उसे किया
जाता है वह एक नॉर्मल यूजर का पासवर्ड
किया जाता है उसे क्योंकि जब भी आप जी भी
यूजर के अंदर स्विच करना चाहते हो
स्टूडियो की हेल्प से तो क्या होता है की
आप जो उसके अंदर जो पासवर्ड इंटर करोगे वो
उसे यूजर का इंटर करोगे जी यूजर
टर्मिनल पर आपने इसको सुडोकू चलाया ना की
उसे जगह स्विच करना चाहते हो दिस इसे डी
बेस्ट एक अच्छे बेनिफिट है की आपको उसके
पासवर्ड की जरूर भी नहीं है और आप रूट बन
सकते हो लेकिन उसके लिए कंडीशन क्या होता
है उसके अंदर इसके अंदर हनी चाहिए
एग्जीक्यूट करते हो तो उसके लोग मेंटेन
किया जाते हैं आपकी मशीन के अंदर
एक फाइल होती है
मेंटेन किया जाता है
रोल प्ले करती है किसी भी यूजर को मैनेज
करने के लिए
क्या कर सकता है
[संगीत]
अगर आपको रूट वाले कम करने या एडमिन वाले
कम करने हैं तो क्या है उसके लिए आपको
क्या करना पड़ेगा इस वीडियो वाली फाइल में
एंट्री होगी और जी भी यूजर की एंट्रीज
फाइल के अंदर की जाति है या जी भी यूजर को
सुडो परमिशन दी जाति है उसको हम यूजर
बोलते हैं
और इसकी जो लोकेशन होती है वो कहां पर
मिलती है आपको देखने को मां को बताता हूं
और वो आपकी स्लैश ईटीसी के अंदर एक
सुवॉयर छोड़ो एक फाइल होती है एस यू टी ओ
यस एक फाइल होती है इसके अंदर यह देखने को
मिलती है यहां पर यह फाइल की लोकेशन होती
है
तो बेसिकली क्या होता है की जब भी आप क्या
करते हो की अगर मैं अटैक की बात करता हूं
की आप एन्यूमरेशन कर लेते हो उसके बाद
आपको क्या की किसी एक यूजर अकाउंट में
इसकी रेट हो जाता है
नॉर्मल यूजर अकाउंट अभी खासकर लाइनेक्स की
बात कर रहा हूं तो अपार क्या होता है की
आपको ये सबसे पहले आप ये चेक करते हो की
मैं इसके अंदर क्या-क्या कर सकता हूं
क्या-क्या नहीं कर सकता क्या सुडो परमिशन
है या नहीं है और नॉर्मली क्या राहत है की
दिउ तू सिक्योरिटी रीजंस कहानी बाहर सुदू
स कमांड को क्या किया था डिसएबल कर दिया
जाता है किसी एक पर्टिकुलर यूजर के लिए
मतलब रूट को छोड़ के या जो एडमिन उनके
छोड़ के बाकी के लिए सुडो कमांड को डिसएबल
कर दिया जाता है दिउ तू सिक्योरिटी रीजंस
और जब भी आप प्रोड्यूसर्स क्रिएशन की बात
कर रहे होंगे तो वहां पर क्या है की आप
चेक करते हो की स्टूडियो के थ्रू की क्या
मैं इस पर्टिकुलर सर्विस के अंदर जा सकता
हूं या नहीं जा सकता तो
इट्स वेरी इंपॉर्टेंट फाइल क्योंकि किसी
भी यूजर को अगर एडमिन वाले कम करने हैं तो
इसी फाइल के अंदर उसकी एंट्री की जाति है
तो उसको एंट्री कैसे की जाति है उसकी क्या
है 1 मिनट का मुझे टाइम दीजिए
ओके सॉरी पर डिस्टरबेंस
लेकिन प्रिंट को लगाया
जब तक इस फाइल के अंदर किसी नॉर्मल यूजर
की एंट्री नहीं होगी तब तक वो क्या कर
सकते आपके सुपीरियर वाले कम नहीं कर सकता
वो भी यहां पर किया जाते हैं वो कैसे आप
कर सकते हो मैं बताता हूं आपको
[संगीत]
कैट करके दिखता हूं 1 मिनट में
की जाति है
यहां पर एंट्री करने से क्या
मिलते हैं
रूट को है या ग्रुप है यह क्या है ग्रुप
है
जिसको सारे
रूट को मिले हुए हैं ऐसे रूट यूजर है इसको
भी सारे
को समझता हूं आपको इसका क्या मतलब होता है
1 मिनट
ओके
अब होस्ट क्या हो सकता है एग्जांपल कोई भी
आईपी एड्रेस हो सकता है कोई भी आईपी
एड्रेस हो सकता है
यहां पर डिपेंड करती है
पर ही आप इसको परमिशन को डिफाइन कर रहे हो
क्या कर रहे हो या पर्टिकुलर आईपी के लिए
पर्टिकुलर नाम
देखने को मिल रहा होगा जो उसके बाद फिर यह
तो यहां पर क्या है जो
विच एवर
कमांड
यू वांट
ओके स्पेलिंग
का मतलब ये था यहां पर बस अभी कमांड्स के
लिए
और जो सेकंड में आपको दिखता हूं यदि जो
आपको परसेंटेज वाली एंट्री है मैं आपको
दिखता हूं बाकी साड़ी चीज से है इसमें
परसेंटेज वाले परसेंटेज करता हूं और यहां
पर आपको देखने को मिलेगा
अब क्या है की आपको पता चल गया होगा अब
यहां पर एक चीज होती है
परमिशन डिफाइन कर सकते हैं दो तरीके से दे
सकते हो किसी भी यूजर को कौन से दो तरीके
से
करना चाहते हैं
हमारा फर्स्ट तरीका
कमांड बाय
मोदी मॉडिफाई
थे परमिशन ऑफ
परमिशन ऑफ तरीका
यूजर के लिए उसको परमिशन ग्रांट कर दीजिए
दूसरा जो तरीका क्या है
मैं आपको
दूसरा जो तरीका है नंबर तू
वी है
सिंपल मतलब
सेक्स कर सकते हैं जैसे की यहां पर क्या
है जो रूट यूजर्स है एक सुपर यूजर है और
युटुब यूजर को क्या हर फाइल के ऊपर कुछ भी
करने की आजादी है तो अब क्या कर सकते हो
की यहां पर क्या कर सकते हो की जैसे की
मैं आपको एक एग्जांपल डीके दिखता हूं की
अगर इसको परमेश्वर परमिट करना हो आपको
किसी भी नॉर्मल के लिए तो मैं क्या कहना
चाहता हूं जैसे मेरा एक यूजर था
डेप्थ्रॉनिक्स मैं यहां पे कैसे एंट्री
बनाऊंगा डी ए एफ आर ओ एन आई क्रॉनिक्स
नंबर तू वाली जो इसमें अलाउ हम तू
एग्जीक्यूट डी कमांड आगे और अदर यूजर विच
ऑलरेडी हैदा परमेश्वर अब डेफ्रॉनिक्स उसके
बाद मैं क्या करूंगा जो बस अभी हॉर्स के
लिए डिफाइन कर रहा हूं इक्वल साइन उसे
करूंगा दें मैं इसके अंदर करूंगा रूट
क्योंकि रूट ऐसा उसे है जिसके पास सारे
परमिशन फाइल के लिए और मैं इसके ऊपर कौन
सी फाइल के ऊपर ऐसे देना चाहता हूं
बेसिकली हमने क्या किया है सभी यूजर के
लिए कर रहा हूं लेकिन हमें ओन्ली रूट
ब्रैकेट में कर रहा हूं दें
कम ऑन की बात कर रहा हूं मैं अब कौन-कौन
से कमांड एक आपको क्या है उसका फूल पद
देना पड़ेगा उसको मान्यता बाइनरी फाइल के
साथ जो कमांड है उर्स के अंदर जो मेरी बिन
डायरेक्टरी है बिन के अंदर एक कमांड है
स्कड सबसे पहले तो मैं क्या करना चाहता
हूं ये कम क्योंकि जी जी कमांड का आप इसकी
यहां पर नाम मेंशन करोगे इसका मतलब क्या
है की उन्हें कमांड पे इस पर्टिकुलर यूजर
को परमीशंस है तो अब यूजर बिन कैट एक वो
कैट कमांड को उसे कर सकता है वैसे नॉर्मल
कर ही सकता है लेकिन अब क्या करना है ओनली
कैट कमांड और कौन सी फाइल के ऊपर स्लाइस
ईटीसी के अंदर जो साइड होगा एस हा ए डी ओ
ब्लू शैडो फाइल है अब जो शैडो फाइल है
इसको क्या है ओनली रूट यूजर ही एक्सेस कर
सकता है इसके अलावा कोई भी इसको एक्सेस
नहीं कर सकता या वो यूजर एक्सेस कर सकता
है जिसको परमिशन दी हुई है अभी मैं क्या
करना चाहता हूं कहना चाहता हूं की जो
डेफ्रॉनिक्स यूजर्स है जो डिप्रोएक्स यूजर
है वो सिर्फ कैट कर सकता है इसके ऊपर शैडो
फाइल
के परमिशन मिल जाति है बट क्या है की जो
शैडो एटीसी शैडो फाइल है उसको कैट कर सकता
है
अब मैं क्या करता हूं अगर मैं कैट करके
दिखाऊं आपको स्लैश एटीसी एस हा ए डी ओ
ब्लू शैडो फाइट अब ये क्या बोल रहा है की
परमिशन डिनाइड आपको परमिशन नहीं है यही पर
अगर मैं ये एंट्रीज फाइल के अंदर बना देता
हूं फाइल के अंदर तो आपको ये परमिशन मिल
जाएगी कैसे हम इसको एग्जिट कर दूंगा सेल
से बाहर ए जाता हूं और सिंपली नैनो करता
हूं अभी के लिए और ए एन ओ नैनो उसके बाद
इंटर
इन रीड ओनली ओके दें दें दें दें आप
यहां पर मैं क्या उसे यूजर का नाम
रूट और
परमिशन करना चाहता हूं
एक्स कीजिए और यस कर दीजिए
[संगीत]
अब यहां पर देखो आपको पता भी चल रहा होगा
की जो इलेक्ट्रॉनिक चीज है ना वह सब क्या
कर सकता है अगर सुडो हिफिन ल उसे करोगे
किसी भी यूजर के लिए आपको पता चल जाएगा
उसे पर्टिकुलर को आगे एन रूट कौन-कौन से
परसों डिफाइंडों के क्या एक सुपरवाइजर
वाले कम कर सकते हैं यहां पर देखो ये दो
पाइल्स के ऊपर उसके परमिशन है ये तो वो
वाले कमांड हो गई उसे कर सकते हैं की ये
फाइल्स है और एक तो ये कैट कर सकता है अब
मैं कैसे करता हूं भैया सुडो आईफोन सोडो
करता हूं उसके बाद मैं क्या करता हूं कैट
करता हूं और स्लैश ईटीसी करता हूं दें एस
यू बी ओ
सेड हो
क्या कर सकते हो पढ़ सकते हो
इसके अब क्या है साड़ी डिटेल पद सकते हो
अदर वाइस आप इसके बगैर नहीं पढ़ सकते तो
मैं एग्जिट कर देता हूं तो इसे आपको पता
चल गया होगा की वे आई जो सुडो फाइल है आप
एक और तरीके से खोल सकते हो वे आई एस यू
दी ओ सुडो सिंपली डायरेक्टली क्या है यहां
पर नैनो का उसे कर रहा है अगर कोई भी
पीडोरा बेस सिस्टम होगा उसके अंदर क्या का
रहा है वे एडिटर के अंदर इसको ओपन कर देगा
अब मैं क्या कर करना चाहता हूं की मैं
डेफिनेट यूजर्स है मैं इसको ऐसे परमिशन
नहीं देना चाहता अपना क्या कहना चाहता हूं
की
इसके अंदर में परमिशन देंगे दिखता हूं
आपको एक और दूसरा तरीका होता है सिंपली
इसको मैं क्या कर रहा हूं
यहां पर मैं कर रहा हूं जो इसके अंदर क्या
कर रहा हूं
पासवर्ड मैं क्या चाहता हूं की जी जी
कमांड पर मैं इसको क्या करना परमिशन देना
चाहता हूं उसे इस कमांड पर क्या किया
पासवर्ड ना करें पासवर्ड फ्रॉम ना करें
अदर वाइस उसे करोगे इस यूजर का डिफरेंस
यूजर का पासवर्ड फ्रॉम करेगा अभी इसलिए
क्यों नहीं किया क्योंकि जस्ट उससे कुछ
सेकंड पहले ही हमने क्या किया स्टूडियो को
पासवर्ड इसमें इंटर किया था तो कुछ सेकंड
के लिए वो मेमोरी में राहत है
तो अब मैं क्या करता हूं यहां पर लिखना
हूं
पास डी और उसके बाद यह दें मैं मैं बोल
रहा हूं की जो सभी कमांड से इसको क्या है
परमिशन है और एक्सेप्ट किस कुमार को
छोड़कर एक्सेप्ट
किया जा सकता है
अभी विदाउट पासवर्ड की तो सिंपली ओके
पीएसईउदो फाइल के अंदर इस पटेल के लिए यह
परमिशन है आप क्या कर सकते हो
वाली कमांड के लिए आपको पासवर्ड फॉर्म
नहीं होगा साड़ी कमेंट चला सकते हो
एक्सेप्ट इस दिस कमांड तो आयोग की मुझे
बता दीजिए की ये समझ में ए गया होगा की
किसी भी नॉर्मल यूजर के लिए अगर आप क्या
करना चाहते हो की सोडोफिल के अंदर चेंज
करना चाहते थे ऐसे कर सकते हो यहां पर
एंट्री में कुछ भी बना सकते हो बेसिकली नो
पार्ट डी लिख सकते हो पर्टिकुलर कमांड को
बैंड कर सकते हो या उन उन कमांड का एड मैं
क्या करता हूं एग्जिट करता हूं
आप यहां बेसिकली क्या कर सकते हो अगर मैं
आपको दिखाऊं ये रहा
ये रहा
है इसके लिए क्या कर सकते हो बेसिकली यहां
पर उन कमांड का नाम लिख सकते हो जो जो
कमांड आप इस ओनली
कमांड का नाम लिख सकते हो जो अलाउ करना
चाहते हो बस और जितनी कमांड्स का यहां पर
क्या करोगे नाम लिखोगे
तब भी क्या होगा वही कमांड उसको अलाउड
होगी पुरी मशीन
के साथ अदर वाइस वो कमांड उसके अलावा कोई
भी कमांड उसको क्या आएगा अलाउड नहीं होगी
देखो यह क्या ना की आप क्या बोल रहे की
जैसे रूट का है वह
देखो जैसे आप रूट का हेज आईटी इस लिखोगे
तो आप क्या की रूट यूजर ही बन जाए प्रकार
से क्योंकि आपने साड़ी परमिशन दे दी इसको
फिर एक बात बताइए रूट में और नॉर्मल यूजर
में अंतर क्या रहेगा क्योंकि उसको आप सुपर
यूजर बना रहे हो लेकिन इन रियल इंडस्ट्री
रियल लाइफ में ऐसा नहीं होता किसी भी एक
यूजर नॉर्मल यूजर कोई ऐसी साड़ी परमेश्वर
नहीं दी जाति
और अगर आपने अगर सिंपली मैंने आपको एक चीज
सिखाई थी की किसी भी फाइल का को मैं
सेकेंडरी ग्रुप सॉरी किसी भी यूजर के लिए
सेकेंडरी ग्रुप कैसे एड कर सकते हो या
किसी उसमें का प्राइमरी ग्रुप कैसे चेंज
कर सकते हो अगर किसी भी नॉर्मल यूजर को
आपने जो सुडोकूप ग्रुप है अगर इसका मेंबर
बना दिया तब भी आपको रूट यूजर वाली
परमीशंस मिल जाएगी आपको इतनी चीज करने की
जरूर नहीं है यह बेसिकली क्या है की जब आस
हार्डिंग का कॉन्सेप्ट होता है
तो वह हार्डिंग की चीज हैं यहां पर वहां
पर क्या है की रूट को कितना एक्सेस है
मतलब रूट के अलावा किसको कितना एक्सेस है
वो साड़ी चीज यहां पर
साड़ी चीज कौन सी कमांड अलाउड होगी कौन सी
कमांड अलाउड नहीं होगी वो साड़ी चीज इधर
ही डिफाइन किया जाति की जाति किसी भी
पार्टिकल के लिए
तो मुझे यह बताइए अभी जो मैंने बताया वह
क्लियर हुआ नहीं हुआ किसी भी एक नॉर्मल
यूजर के लिए
क्योंकि यहां पर यही एंट्री है यहां पर
यूजर का नाम लिखना है
सभी होस्ट के लिए यहां पर क्या है होस्ट
नाम लिख सकते हो या आईपी एड्रेस भी मेंशन
कर सकते हो या यहां पर क्या जो यूजर का
नाम ले सकते हो जैसे मैंने रूट यूजर दिया
था या ग्रुप का नाम भी दे सकते हो जो यहां
पर क्या साड़ी कमांड्स है यहां यहां क्या
होल की जगह आप क्या कमांड भी मेडिसिन कर
सकते हो अगर आप चाहते हो की नहीं की मेरा
ये एक एडमिन यूजर ही है और मेरे को इतनी
कमांड की परमिशन देनी है लेकिन इसको क्या
करना है की पासवर्ड प्रोवाइड एन पासवर्ड
नहीं है फ्रॉम करवाना है तो उसके लिए क्या
करोगे उससे पहले नो पास डी मेंशन कर डॉग
जैसे की अगर मैं इसको अभी क्या कंट्रोल
एक्स कर देता हूं सिंपली यस
ओके
सभी के लिए और यहां पर मैंने यहां पर लिख
दिया और मैं क्या चाहता हूं की अभी नो
पार्ट डी यह फ्रॉम ना करें उसके बाद यहां
पर लिख रहा हूं मैं उन कमांड का नाम जो
इसको सब अलाउड है जैसे की मैं चाहता हूं
की एक कमांड होती है एफडीएस करके जैसे मैं
चाहता हूं की इसको यही कमांड अलाउड है यू
एस आर यू एस आर और एस बी
इन फूल बाउंड्री पास देना पड़ेगा आपको फूल
पाठ उसके बाद यूजर और यूजर और और उसके बाद
में क्या है
स्पेस सेपरेट भी दे सकता हूं
और मैं क्या चाहता हूं की ये पासवर्ड भी
चेंज कर लो
हटके कम करना होगा रूट वाले तो उसके लिए
सब उसको क्या है की
परमिशन दिया क्योंकि रिटायरमेंट उसको यूजर
आईडी करने की थी इस नॉर्मल को और एक
पासवर्ड चेंज करने की क्योंकि किसी को एड
करना है उसका पासवर्ड चेंज करना है तो
उसको इन दो बाउंड्री फाइल परमिशन चाहिए थी
लेकिन उसके लिए क्या डी मतलब ये पासवर्ड
फॉर्म नहीं करेगा अदर वाइस अगर आप इसको
सिंपली ऐसे भी लिख सकते हो
आगे मत कंट्रोल इसको क्या कर रहा हूं
तो ये पासवर्ड फ्रॉम करेगा नेफ्रॉनिक्स
उसे का तो ये तरीका था किसी भी नॉर्मल
यूजर के लिए आप सुडो फाइल के लिए एंट्री
कैसे बना सकते हो
एक्चुअली भाई आईपी का मेरे पास अभी
एग्जांपल पट अप करने के लिए क्योंकि अभी
मशीन में इतने आईपी है नहीं अवेलेबल मेरे
पास ज्यादा मशीन है नहीं क्योंकि जो मेरा
मशीन है वो शायद वो एनवायरनमेंट है और
सैंडबॉक्स एनवायरनमेंट को मैं टच नहीं कर
सकता क्योंकि जितने अभी इसके अलावा इस
मशीन के अलावा जो मेरी फ्री मशीन है तीन
मशीन है वो सेंड बॉक्स एनवायरनमेंट में चल
रही है उनकी सेटिंग में चेंज नहीं कर सकता
आपको प्रैक्टिकल दिखाने के लिए हां बट एक
कम कीजिए आप लोग
यह खुद से करके देखिए एक बार
क्योंकि मुझे करके देखोगे तो कुछ ज्यादा
मजा आएगा
[संगीत]
यहां पर चाहिए एक आर्टिकल है
स्क्रीनशॉट
कर सकते हो अपने लिए तो यह आयोग की मुझे
ये बता दीजिए अभी
यह समझ में अगर आपको हां एक चीज बता देता
हूं आपको अगर ग्रुप के लिए आप क्या करना
चाहते हो की किसी भी एक आपके एनवायरनमेंट
में कुछ लोग कम कर रहे हैं उनको एडमिन
चाहिए एक्सेस किसी पर्टिकुलर कमांड के लिए
बाइनरी फाइल्स के लिए बट क्या की वो एक
नहीं है वो तीन से कर लोग हैं तो मैं हर
के लिए तो एंट्री नहीं बनाऊंगा मैं सिंपली
क्या करूंगा एक ग्रुप क्रिएट कर दूंगा और
ग्रुप क्रिएट करने के बाद वो उसे ग्रुप का
मेंबर उन तीन लोगों को बना दूंगा एग्जांपल
लिया की तीन लोगों के जिनको एडमिन वाले
कुछ कम करने हैं उनको उनको परमिशन चाहिए
सुडो फाइल के लिए सोडोफिल के अंदर बट क्या
कीमत तीन एंट्री बनाने की बजे मैं क्या कर
सकता हूं की मैं एक ग्रुप में उनको एड कर
दूंगा और उसे ग्रुप को भी मैं परमिशन दे
सकता हूं कैसे जैसे ये रहा मैं कैसे
करूंगा यहां पर हम आपको नहीं है की ये खुद
प्रैक्टिस करके देखिए एक बार आप लोग करने
को मैं दिखा दूंगा करके नो इशू बट की आप
लोग प्रैक्टिस करके देखिए अगर नहीं होता
तो मुझे बताइए मैं प्रैक्टिकल करके दिखा
दूंगा
यहां पर जैसे की कोई भी एक ग्रुप क्रिएट
करना आप अपनी मशीन में
स्टेप बताता हूं स्टेप वन
स्टेप वन क्या करना है आपको
सी आर
क्रिएट ए ग्रुप
नाम
[संगीत]
शुरू कर दो और वहां पर आपको क्या है
एंट्री बनाने कौन सी एंट्री बनानी है जहां
पर परसेंटेज सिंबल के साथ ग्रुप का नाम
क्या है
रूट वाली क्योंकि एक रूट यूजर है मधुर रूट
वाले उसको रेफर कर रहा हूं दें मैं क्या
कर रहा हूं आपकी बात मैं सिर्फ कौन-कौन सी
परमिशन दे रहा हूं इसको इन तीनों ग्रुपऑन
की वो क्या कम कर सकते हैं ये जो एड कर
सकते हैं और यूजर और उसके वो पासवर्ड
डिफाइन कर सकते हैं तो ये वाली ये दो
परमिशन दे रहा था और ओनली कॉपी और ये रहा
इसके अलावा कोई परमिशन नहीं दे रहा हूं
आपको क्या करना है की यह हो गया है
लुक केवल की ओके यू सी केवल
तू
उसे
और
कमांड और नोट
यह पता करना है
देखो
प्रोफाइल
स्क्रीनशॉट के साथ भेज सकते हो या
स्क्रीनशॉट के साथ आप उधर भी सेंड कर
दीजिए की आप क्या-क्या किया
बताइए
बताइए चाट में बताइए हो जाएगा
उसे करके
सेकेंडरी ग्रुप का पार्ट बनाना है इन
तीनों यूजर को और फिर करना है
फिर और जो भी रिकॉर्डिंग रहेगी
यह जो लास्ट मिनट आपको देखने को मिल रही
है
की आपको यूजर आईडी कमांड करके देखनी है
किसी भी एक यूजर के लिए पासवर्ड उसका
पासवर्ड चेंज करना है इसके अलावा और एक
कमांड चला के देख लीजिए क्या
इसके अलावा वैसे वेरीफाई कर सकते हो कोई
भी एक और कमांड होती है जिसे एक नॉर्मल
यूजर नहीं चला सकता फेडेक्स कमांड होती है
वो कमांड होती है तो उसको चला के देख
लीजिए क्या वो कम कर रही है इन दो के
अलावा इन तीनों युद्ध के लिए वो कर सकते
हो आप अदर वाइस
और मैं वेरीफाई हो गया
एड कीजिए और उसको वेरीफाई
नहीं कर पन चाहिए
उधर भी एक कम कीजिए स्क्रीनशॉट लेक भेज
दीजिए
बता दीजिए एक बार हो गया तो चलो कंटिन्यू
करते हैं
नया टॉपिक पढ़ने हैं अपना दूसरा पासवर्ड
मैनेजमेंट
यस नो
ओके चलो बात करते हैं कंटिन्यू करते हैं
देखो अब किसी भी पासवर्ड मैनेजमेंट की बात
करते हैं अभी किसी वीडियो का पासवर्ड चेंज
करना उसके लिए कमांड होती है
इसका पासवर्ड चेंज करना चाहता हूं सिंपली
यूजर का नाम अगर विदाउट यूजरनेम आप सिंपली
कमांड फायर करोगे पासवर्ड चेंज कर देगा
अगर आप क्या करोगे पार्ट डी के साथ ये जो
नाम डॉग तो आप क्या करेगा उसे यूजर नाम का
उसे का क्या करो आप पासवर्ड चेंज करो
डिफरेंस का पासवर्ड चेंज करता हूं यहां पर
क्या लिखोगे न्यू पासवर्ड मैं कोई भी एक
नया पासवर्ड एड कर रहा हूं
उसके बाद फिर से टाइप करना है
इसके लिए होता है पासवर्ड चेंज के लिए अब
इन कैसे हम अपना पासवर्ड भूल गए तो कैसे
हम अपना पासवर्ड चेंज करेंगे
तो हमें देखो क्या है की अगर हम पासवर्ड
भूल गए आप किसी भी ऑर्गेनाइजेशन में आप कम
कर रहे हो लेकिन
पासवर्ड अपना भूल गए तो पहले बात अगर आपको
अपना पासवर्ड चाहिए तो उसके लिए क्या क्या
चाहिए मेरे पासवर्ड चेंज करने के लिए आपको
रूट यूजर चाहिए होगा जो आपको दिया नहीं
जाता आपको क्या करना होगा अपने एडमिन
अथॉरिटी से रिक्वेस्ट करना होगा की मैं
पासवर्ड भूल गया मुझे पासवर्ड प्रोवाइड की
जाए बट ये कोई रीजन के लिए क्योंकि हां
अगर आप एक ऐसा कम कर रहे हो की आप
लाइनेक्स एडमिन का ही कम देखते हो आपके
पास थोड़ी रोड यूजर के हैं तो आप इस तरीके
से अपना पासवर्ड चेंज कर सकते हैं लेकिन
अब देखो
यहां पर छोटा सा सवाल आपके दिमाग में आना
चाहिए की अब ये जो पासवर्ड है उसे सिस्टम
को कैसे पता चला है कहानी से तो एक्चुअल
में पासवर्ड हो रहा होगा ना और कैसे तो ये
रेफरेंस ले रहे हो की हां ये पासवर्ड है
यहां पर स्टॉल करना है और जब आप पासवर्ड
लॉगिन करते हो तो ये मैच करता है और ये
पासवर्ड है इसका लॉगिन सक्सेसफुल हो जाते
हो तो यह सिस्टम को पता चला है
मैं आपको बताता हूं एक फाइल होती है डीसी
के अंदर शैडो फाइल और एक नॉर्मल यूजर को
उसे फाइल को कोई भी परमिशन नहीं होती ओनली
रूट यूजर कैन एक्सेसोट
तो कौन सी फाइल होती है जिसकी मैं बात कर
रहा हूं पटेल करता हूं और मैं कैट करता
हूं स्लैश ईटीसी के अंदर एक फाइल होती है
शैडो एस हा ए डी ओ ब्लू शैडो फाइट होती है
जिसके अंदर आपकी इस मशीन के सारे पासवर्ड
स्टोर होते हैं जितने भी यूजर्स हैं सभी
के पासवर्ड जो मेरा रूट यूजर्स है उसका ये
पासवर्ड है और मेरा डिस्ट्रॉनिक्स यूजर है
उसका मेरा ये पासवर्ड यहां पर स्टोर है
इसके अंदर कुछ बहुत सारे एंट्रीज और हैं
किसका क्या मतलब है हम आपको डिटेल में
बताता हूं लेकिन एक चीज ध्यान में रखना की
जो ये फाइल है इसमें सिर्फ किसको प्रमोशंस
होती है रूट यूजर इसको एक्सेस कर सकता है
एडरवाइज किसी को भी इसका एक्सेस नहीं दिया
जाता छिपकली इसकी एक-एक एंट्री के बड़े
में आपको एक्सप्लेन करता हूं चलो बात करते
हैं आपको इनका क्या मतलब है इनके बड़े में
बात करते हैं
वेरी इंटरेस्टिंग टॉपिक बहुत मजा आने वाला
है अभी इस टॉपिक में
चलो
[संगीत]
फूल स्क्रीन पर आपको दिखा देता हूं
मैं थोड़ा सा अलग कर देता हूं सारे
पैरामीटर क्या है एक बार अच्छे से समझ में
ए जाए जैसे इतना स्पेस दे देता हूं वैसे
वापस स्पेस होगा नहीं लेकिन मैं आपको यह
पैरामीटर अलग करके दिखा देता हूं आपको
अच्छे से समझ में ए जाए
एक
दो
तीन कर पांच छह साथ आठ ये कुछ एंट्रीज
होती है इनके अंदर का क्या मतलब होता है
जो फर्स्ट वाला
नाम
कंट्री देखने को मिल रही है कंट्रोल भी अब
इस एंट्री को ब्रेक करते हैं
यहां पर
अब इसमें जो एंट्री पहले वाली एंट्री है
इसमें इससे पता चला है की
हेसिंग एल्गोरिथम कोचिंग
पासवर्ड
तो कौन सा साल्ट है इन दोनों में वह
इनफॉरमेशन रहती है अब उसके बाद जो नेक्स्ट
आपको देखने को मिल रहा है यह है आपका
वह पासवर्ड जो इनके प्रिंट पासवर्ड बोल
सकता हूं आई एन सी आर ए पी
टेड पासवर्ड
यह वह इंक्रिप्टेड पासवर्ड
क्या है ये पूरा पूरा इंक्रिप्टेड पासवर्ड
है यहां पर दो इनफॉरमेशन रहती है इसमें एक
हैकिंग एल्गोरिथम की और एक साल की आप
बेसिकली क्या 512 उसे हो रही है बेसिकली
क्योंकि अभी
रिसेंटली जितने
साफ 512 एल्गोरिथम उसे हो रही है अब बात
करते हैं नेक्स्ट नेक्स्ट जो आपको दिखाई
दे रहा है यहां पर
19536 इसका क्या मतलब है
उसकी डेट है और कहां से अकाउंट करता है ये
जनवरी फर्स्ट
है और जो यह ए रहा यह नंबर ऑफ डेज मतलब की
जी दिन मेरा पासवर्ड चेंज किया गया था इस
मशीन का
वह फर्स्ट जेनरेशन
अभी तक इतने दिन पहले पासवर्ड चेंज किया
गया था इस मशीन का ओके ये है लास्ट
पासवर्ड चेंज डेट कब पासवर्ड चेंज किया
गया था इस मशीन का ये हुआ है नंबर ऑफ डेज
में दिखाई दे रहा है यहां पर आपको जीरो
दिखाई दे रहा होगा इसका क्या मतलब है इधर
जीरो
एंट्री आई है एक मिनट
यहां पर जो एंट्री आई है
यहां पर रहती है
तो मतलब क्या है की आपको इतने दिन तक
पासवर्ड
अब नेक्स्ट इसका क्या मतलब यहां पर इसका
मतलब है
यह मैक्सिमम नंबर ऑफ डेज मैक्सिमम
नंबर ऑफ डेज मैक्सिमम नंबर ऑफ डेज
मतलब कितने दिन के बाद आपको क्या करना है
पासवर्ड चेंज करना है मतलब नहीं इतने दिन
के बाद मतलब आपको पासवर्ड चेंज कभी करना
नहीं आता मतलब कभी भी पासवर्ड चेंज करने
को फोर्स नहीं किया की हां इतने दिन के
बाद आपको चेंज करना ही करना है ऐसा यहां
पर मेंशन नहीं किया गया है अब नेक्स्ट जो
सेवन आपको दिखाई दे रहा है
आपको देखने को मिल रहा है इसका मतलब क्या
है
पासवर्ड चेंज किया तो यह का मतलब है की
इतने दिन पहले वार्निंग्स हो जाएगी आपको
पासवर्ड चेंज करना है क्योंकि आपका
पासवर्ड एक्सपायर होने जा रहा है और यहां
पर
जो देखने को मिलती है लास्ट वाली जो है
आपको मिलती है आपको एंट्री देखने को
एक्सपायरी डेट
देखने को मिलेंगे
दोस्त है नेक्स्ट आपको देखने मिला इन
एक्टिव इन एक्टिव
पीरियड्स यहां पर एक्सपायरी डेट
कंप्लीट
1234 5678 यही वो आठ एंट्री मगर सीरियल
नंबर दे देता हूं इसको तो आपको समझ में
अच्छे से ए जाएगा देखिए
ओके अब ये रहा ये थर्ड नंबर है
तो यह चाहिए वह एंट्री है जो आपके सामने
अब मैं आपको समझने की कोशिश करता हूं
कैसे अकाउंट किया जाता है
पर एग्जांपल
की यहां पर मेरा एक दिन मेरा पासवर्ड चेंज
होगा लास्ट चेंज डेट हायफेंहदी मतलब मेरा
जी दिन मेरा एक दिन पासवर्ड चेंज हुआ पर
एग्जांपल की मेरा पासवर्ड चेंज होगा कल ही
हुआ था कोई एग्जांपल मैं पासवर्ड कल चेंज
हुआ था अब जो ये आपको दिखाई दे रहा है
मिनिमम डेज नाम डेज आईफोन एम वेलकम कितने
दिन के बाद में पासवर्ड चेंज कर सकता हूं
इतने दिन के बाद मैं पासवर्ड चेंज कर सकता
हूं यदि यहां पर जीरो है इसका मतलब क्या
है किसी भी मोमेंट आई कैन चेंज मी पासवर्ड
अगर यहां मिनिमम नंबर
यहां पर मेंशन है उसका मतलब है की उसने
दिन तक आप अपने पासवर्ड को चेंज नहीं कर
सकते इतने दिन होने के बाद ही आप क्या कर
सकते अपने पासवर्ड को चेंज कर सकते हो अब
आपको यहां पर दिखाई दे रहा होगा नेक्स्ट
डेज आईफोन
में हमने मैक्सिमम डेज 10 रख दिए इसका
मतलब है 10 दिन के बाद मेरा पासवर्ड
एक्सपायर हो जाएगा 10 दिन के पास मुझे
पासवर्ड चेंज करना ही करना है ये
इसका मतलब है नेक्स्ट डेज 10 दिन रख दिए
अब यहां पर मैं क्या वार्निंग पीरियड रखना
हूं वार्निंग डेज में मतलब वार्निंग मैं
यहां रख दिया वार्निंग डेज तू तो इसका
मतलब जैसे ही 8 दिन हो जाएंगे तो 10 दिन
पहले पासवर्ड एक्सप्रेस
दो दिन पहले वार्निंग देना शुरू कर दिया
की भैया आपका पासवर्ड एक्सपायर होने वाला
है तो प्लीज आप अपना पासवर्ड चेंज कर
लीजिए तो यहां पर क्या है उसे वार्निंग
डेज का मतलब ये है अब यहां पे होता है वो
एक्सप्रेशन डेट पापा एक्सपायर अपने आप ये
ए जाए जैसे आपको मेंशन कर देते हो यहां पर
मैक्सिमम डेज
फिर भी अब हो गया इन एक्टिव डेज आई है
इसका मतलब क्या होता है
की चलो अभी दो दिन बच्चे हैं तो कल कर
लूंगा पासवर्ड चेंज और आपने सोचा की कल कर
लूंगा और उसे दिन आपको टाइम नहीं मिला
अपने अपने मशीन को ऑन नहीं किया है या
आपने मशीन को ऑन किया सोचा की ओके शाम को
कर लूंगा अभी तो बच्चा हुआ दिन और शाम को
सुद्दनली आपको कुछ कम आया और अब चले गए और
आपने अपनी मशीन को शुरू डॉ किया चले गए और
आपको याद ही नहीं रहा की आज आपको पासवर्ड
चेंज करना है तो उसे कैसे में क्या होगा
आपका पासवर्ड हो जाएगा एक्स पर इस चीज को
इस चीज से बचाने के लिए थोड़ा हमने क्या
किया ठीक है भूल किसी से भी हो जाति है तो
वो चीज देखते हुए यहां पर क्या हुआ आगे को
मेंशन किया तो इन एक्टिव डेज में मैंने पर
एग्जांपल दो दिन रख दिए ओके तो अब यहां पर
दो दिन रख दिया इसका मतलब क्या है की अगर
आप पासवर्ड चेंज करना भूल भी गए तो 10 दिन
के बाद आपके पास दो दिन और हैं लेकिन वो
दो दिन और क्या है जैसे ही आप की मशीन में
लॉगिन करोगे तो पुराने पासवर्ड के साथ वो
से टाइम आपको क्या करेगा की ये पासवर्ड
एक्सपायर हो गया है प्लीज जेनरेट डी न्यू
पासवर्ड से टाइम आपको दूसरा पासवर्ड क्या
करना पड़ेगा चेंज करना पड़ेगा
है वह पासवर्ड जैसे जेनरेट हो जाए उसके
बाद इस पासवर्ड से आपकी मशीन
कर पाएगी मतलब यह है अब सपोज आपने क्या
किया 11वां और बाद में दिन भी आपने मशीन
में लॉगिन नहीं किया और आपने उसे पासवर्ड
को चेंज नहीं किया अब मैं बोला की नहीं
मैं तो चेंज ही नहीं करूंगा जिसको उखाड़ना
उखाड़ लो अगर ऐसा कुछ है तो अगर आपने उन
एक्टिव डेज को क्रॉस कर लिया उसके बाद
क्या होगा की आप क्या मशीन का पासवर्ड
एक्सपायर हो जाएगा आप मशीन में कभी भी
लॉगिन नहीं कर पाएंगे अब ये कम पूर्ण कर
सकता है अब आपके एक बार मशीन का पासवर्ड
एक्सपायर होगा इन एक्यूरेट क्रॉस कर लिए
तो यहां पर आप उसको ट्रबलीशूट कैसे कर
सकते हो आपके पास दो ही चीज हैं यहां पर
आपको अपने ऑडियो सिस्टम एडमिनिस्ट्रेटर से
बात करनी होगी या तो वो मैन्युअल आपके
पासवर्ड को चेंज करके रिसेट करके आपको
देगा एडरवाइज आपको क्या करना होगा आपको
क्या करेगा आपका जो सिस्टम एडमिनिस्ट्रेटर
है वो इस लास्ट चेंज डेट है
आप इस रेंज में ए जाओगे मैक्सिमम वाले में
और अपना पासवर्ड चेंज कर पाओगे
अपना पासवर्ड चेंज कर पाओगे फिर से आपने
मशीन को उसे कर पाओगे ट्रबल्स तू सूट
स्टेप यही थी तो ये था पासवर्ड मैनेजमेंट
का पूरा किया इस तरीके से आपकी किसी भी
लाइनेक्स मशीन के अंदर या मशीन के अंदर
में होता था तो सर्वर रूम होते हैं जो
आपका रियल एनवायरनमेंट है रियल इंडस्ट्री
है जहां पर पासवर्ड को मैनेज किया था तो
इस तरीके से मैनेज किया जाता है पासवर्ड
को मैनेज करने के लिए दिस इस अलसो डी
पार्ट ऑफ पोज हार्ड नहीं
है सबको क्लियर ए गया होगा
बताइए मुझे एक बार
चाट में बताइए
यस नो
ओके चलो अब क्या होता है
लेकिन इससे पहले मैं एक चीज दिखता हूं आप
लोगों को
मानो बैंड हो
ओके यह चीज हो गई
अब क्या होता है की जो भी इनफॉरमेशन है
शैडो फाइल वाली इनफॉरमेशन जो भी मैंने
आपको क्या है अभी शो किया ये इनफॉरमेशन
कहां पर स्टोर रहती है इनफॉरमेशन आप कहां
पर देख सकते हो
बहुत ही आसन में क्योंकि आगे तो जो मैंने
अभी आपका स्लाइस सीटीसी शैडो के अंदर जो
इनफॉरमेशन है वो क्या किया नंबर ऑफ डेज
आपको कभी भी कैलकुलेट नहीं रहेंगे याद
नहीं रहेंगे तो अगर आपको इजी वे में देखना
है उसके लिए एक फाइल होती है आपकी मशीन
में कैट करता हूं स्लैश ईटीसी के अंदर एक
लॉगिन दास नाम से फाइल होती है यहां पर
आपको बहुत साड़ी इनफॉरमेशन देखने को मिलती
है बेसिकली जब भी एक नया यूजर आपकी मशीन
में एड होता है या आप उसको डिफाइन करते
हैं तो उसके अंदर डिपल जो सेटिंग होती है
वह साड़ी की साड़ी सेटिंग्स यही से ली
जाति है देखिए आपको पता चल जाए इसमें
क्या-क्या चीज दी हुई है मैं आपको बताता
हूं ये रहा
स्टार्टिंग
[संगीत]
शिवा शिवा ओके शिवा नाम
रिक्वायर्ड ओके ओके ओके ओके ओके
इसके अंदर दूसरा देखो यहां पर इसी के इसी
को इनफॉरमेशन पता चल जाएगी की आपका जो
नॉर्मल है उसके अकाउंट आईडी क्या होगी
यूजर आईडी क्या होगी ग्रुप आईडी क्या होगी
यहां पर देखो यूआईडी मिनिमम थाउजेंड होएगी
ठीक है और मैक्सिमम कितनी रहेगी आपकी और
जो सिस्टम अकाउंट और सर्विस अकाउंट ओपन
इस फाइल के अंदर बहुत कुछ दिखाई देता है
जैसे की यहां पर देखने को मिल जाएगी
साफ आई वांट तू का उसे किया जा रहा है
इसमें हेजिंग एल्गोरिथम का
मैक्सिमम ग्राउंड बहुत कुछ इसमें साड़ी
इनफॉरमेशन आपको देखना मिलती है बाय डिपोज
जब भी आपकी मशीन में कोई भी एक यूजर को
क्रिएट किया जाता है अगर आप चाहते हो की
आपकी मशीन
किया जाए उसके अंदर अगर जो पासवर्ड यूजिंग
है जो मैंने अभी आपको एक फिगर के साथ
दिखाई और उसमें कुछ चेंज के साथ आपके आया
किसी भी चाहते हो की कोई भी नया यूजर आए
उसका पासवर्ड 10 दिन के बाद चेंज होना
चाहिए मिनिमम जीरो वार्निंग डेज वो चाहते
हो तो आपको क्या करना पड़े लॉगिन पोली
फाइल को चेंज करना होगा उसके बाद क्या
होगा जितने भी नए यूजर क्रिएट होंगे मशीन
में इस लॉगिन देव की सेटिंग के हिसाब से
ही क्रिएट होंगे तो आईटी इसे डी वेरी
इंपॉर्टेंट फाइल
अब हम चेंज करने की जरूर नहीं है इसके एक
और कमांड होती है ये साड़ी इनफॉरमेशन देख
ले लेकिन
यहां से भी इनफॉरमेशन काफी डिटेल और काफी
अच्छे से अब आपको ज्यादा क्लियर इनफॉरमेशन
देखने को मिलेगी देखो लास्ट पासवर्ड चेंज
कब किया गया इस मशीन का जनवरी 27 2023
पासवर्ड कभी नहीं होगा पासवर्ड ने
एक्टिवेट
नंबर ऑफ डेज बिटवीन पासपोर्ट चेंज जीरो
मिनी मैक्सिमम नंबर ऑफ डेज बिटवीन पास पर
चेंज
साड़ी चीज आप देखो आपको क्या है ना तो डेज
में कैलकुलेट करने की जरूर थी ना ही कुछ
कैलकुलेट करने की जरूर थी आपको क्या है अब
चेंज कमांड की हेल्प से सबको देखने को
मिलता है और इस कमांड की हेल्प से इस
पैरामीटर को अब चेंज भी कर सकते हैं वो
कैसे कर सकते हैं देखो मैं करके नहीं
दिखाऊंगा क्योंकि ये मेरी क्या है में
अटैकर मशीन है मेरी फैंटास्टिक मशीन है
अगर मैं कुछ सेटिंग अगर मैं चेंज करके भूल
गया तो मेरे साथ प्रॉब्लम हो जाएगी
क्योंकि मैं भी बहुत साड़ी चीज भूलने की
आदत है भूल गया था प्रॉब्लम हो जाएगी
नेक्स्ट टाइम आपको क्या करता हूं की एक
उसके अंदर आपको दिखा दूंगा की कैसे चेंज
करते हैं उसका मन को आप चाहे तो अपनी मशीन
में उसे करके एक बार प्रैक्टिस कर सकते हो
क्योंकि इसके साथ में क्या-क्या पासवर्ड
चेंज करना बोले क्योंकि मेरे पास रूट वाली
प्रॉब्लम है क्योंकि रूट के साथ ज्यादा
टास्क करते हैं और वो अगर एक बार भूल गया
तो भूल गया
लेकिन मैं आपको कमांड बता दूंगा कैसे आपको
उसे करना है यह देखो अगर मैं क्या करूं
मतलब आप स्मॉल एम का मतलब यहां पर क्या है
मिनिमम आगे कितना देना चाहते हो मिनिमम
आगे मैंने आपको बताया था तो यहां पर जीरो
ही मतलब मिनिमम वैल्यू होती है ना अगर वन
तू करना चाहते हो की एक दिन के बाद ही
चाहिए उससे पहले चेंज नहीं हो मैं ऐसा कुछ
नहीं जाता हूं मिनिमम आगे चाहता हूं मैं
जीरो उसके बाद हिफिन कैपिटल एम मतलब क्या
है की मैक्सिमम इमेज कितनी देना चाहता हूं
मतलब मैं चाहता हूं की मेरा पासवर्ड है 15
डेज के बाद एक्सपायर हो जाए 15 दिन के बाद
क्या हो जाए पासवर्ड चेंज करना पड़े यूजर
को उसके बाद हिफिन ब्लू मतलब मैं वार्निंग
वार्निंग डेज देना चाहता हूं आईफोन ब्लू
उसके बाद वार्निंग डेज
[संगीत]
कितनी देता हूं मैं जाता हूं जीरो सेवन
डेज वन इन दे देना चाहता हूं दें उसके बाद
है
कितने देना चाहता हूं दो
दिन तो और उसके बाद किस यूजर के लिए देना
चाहता हूं जैसे मेरा काली हो जाता है
अब ये क्या है की
15 दिन के बाद उसका पासवर्ड एक्सपायर हो
जाएगा
अगर 15 दिन के बाद उसके बाद दो दिन और है
उसे पासवर्ड को चेंज करके से टाइम देखा
दूसरा पासवर्ड आपको उसे करने का और ये
पट्टी को यूजर के पास इसका मतलब ये है
आईफोन एम मिनिमम मैक्सिमम वार्निंग इन
नेक्स्ट तू डेज एक और कमांड में अगर आप
ऐसा करते हो की एक सी हा ए जी ए चेंज
कमांड का आपने उसे किया हिफिन दी उसे किया
और अगर आपने जीरो कर दिया और उसके बाद लिख
दिया यूजरनेम काली इसका मतलब क्या है इस
कमांड का मतलब मैं आपको समझा देता हूं
आईटी फोर्सेस डी यूजर
तू
अपडेट
पासवर्ड
ऑन
नेक्स्ट लॉगिन नेक्स्ट लोग
अब जैसे ही क्या करोगे जैसे आज जैसे आपने
क्या कर दिया अगर यह चेंज कमांड फायर किया
आपने अपनी मशीन में उसके बाद आपने क्या
किया था जैसे ही लोग आउट किया हुआ आपकी
मशीन में से तो दोबारा लॉगिन करोगे तो उसे
टाइम आपको ये बोलेगा की आपको पासवर्ड चेंज
करना है इस कमांड का ये मतलब है इसका मां
क्या क्या मतलब है की आपको मिनिमम डेज कुछ
नहीं है कभी भी चेंज कर सकते हो 15 दिन के
बाद आपको चेंज करना है 15 दिन के अंदर कभी
भी कर लो साथ दिन वार्निंग पीरियड आपका इन
एक्टिव प्रिंट हुआ है और इसलिए डर के लिए
तो आई होप ये सबको समझ में ए गया होगा की
किसी भी पासवर्ड को कैसे भी आप चेंज कर
सकते हो आपकी मशीन के अंदर पासवर्ड
अजिंक्य बेसिकली कैसे मैनेजमेंट करते थे
वेरी इंपॉर्टेंट टॉपिक
वो सेटिंग में काफी उसे किया जाता है इसका
और हर जगह इंडस्ट्री में आपको देखने को
मिलेगा ही मिलेगा जहां पर लाइनेक्स है
एक चीज बताता हूं मैं आप लोगों को जब भी
एक यूजर आईडी किया जाता है
एड इन योर मशीन
फ्लैश ईटीसी
के अंदर
दूसरी जगह आपको देखने को मिलेगी
शैडो फाइल एस हा ए डी ओ ब्लू शैडो फाइल के
अंदर आपको देखने को मिलेगी तीसरी जो
एंट्री है वह आपको कहां देखने को मिलेगी
एक यूजर की रेसिपी के अंदर एक है
तो अब हम आपको एक चीज बताओ एक वेरी
इंपॉर्टेंट चीज की अब किसी के भी यूजर के
पासवर्ड को डिसएबल कैसे कर सकते हैं वह
चीज खत्म
कर सकते हैं मैं आपको दिखता हूं पर
एग्जांपल मैं क्या करता हूं
कैट करता हूं स्लैश सिटी सी और एक शैडो
फाइल है मेरी एस हा ए दी ओ ब्लू साडो फाइल
है काफी टाइम से कम कर रहा है
डिसएबल करना चाहता हूं इसके पासवर्ड को
बेसिकली मैं इस वीडियो को डिसएबल करना
चाहता हूं कैसे कर सकता हूं मैं यूजर को
क्योंकि इसका कम खत्म
या तो आपके पास तीन तरीके हैं पहले तरीका
[संगीत]
सॉरी
अगर आप में उसे करना सिखाऊंगा डोंट वारी
क्योंकि बीच में हमने कमांड छोटी थी बहुत
साड़ी वहां भी है आपको क्या करना है जब
इसको डिसएबल करना है सिंपली पहले भी अगर
आप उसे करो तो सिंपली प्रेस आई इंसर्ट मोड
आपको दिखाई दे रहा होगा उसके बाद आपको
क्या करना चेंज करना है तो ये रहा यहां पर
मेरा ये कर्सर है अभी डॉलर के ऊपर इससे
पहले आपको क्या करना है दो
सिंपली दो बैंक्स और लगा दिया आपने और
क्या करो आप इसको इसके बाद कर दो कीबोर्ड
पर और सिंपली अब ये क्या है शॉप मोड में ए
गया दें आपको क्या करना है
अब ये क्या कर दिया आपने अगर मैं आपको कैट
करके दिखाऊं तो आपने क्या कर दिया इसको
डिसएबल कर दिया इसको क्या कर दिया जिससे
बाल अब यहां पे देख रहा है ये दो में साइन
देख रहे हैं इसका मतलब क्या है की आप यूजर
क्या है की स्विच नहीं कर पाएगा मतलब किसी
भी वजह से उसमें क्या है आपने डिसएबल कर
दिया इसके पासवर्ड को नॉर्मल स्विच करके
दिखता हूं अगर तो हम कर भी पाएंगे बट
अग्रवाल किसी भी दूसरी तरफ से हम इसके
अंदर स्विचिंग कुछ भी कर सकता है इसके
अलावा अगर ये किसी भी नॉर्मल जैसे कोशिश
करेगा एग्जिट करता हूं उसके बाद सो दास दी
ए एफ आर ओ एन आई एक्स इलेक्ट्रॉनिक
ओके इसका मतलब पासवर्ड डायल करता हूं
बिल्कुल रेड पासवर्ड है
अब ये क्या है ये रुक गया है ऑथेंटिकेशन
फेलियर दिखा रहा है अगर मैं फिर से अगर हम
आप करके दिखता हूं पासवर्ड बिल्कुल राइट
दाल रहा हूं मैं
क्योंकि हमने क्या किया
ओके तो अगर एक तरीका यह होता है
गुड अप्रोच बिकॉज़ क्योंकि अगर शैडो फाइल
के साथ छेड़छाड़ करोगे किसी में कोई गलत
एंट्री बना दी तो आपकी मशीन में स्लो हो
जाएगी
क्या होता है की आपको क्या करना है यूजर
मोड का उसे करना है उसके बाद हिफिन कैपिटल
ल का उसे करना जिसको भी डिसएबल करना है
आपको उसको क्या करना है आपको सिंपली यूजर
का नाम लेना है जैसे की मैं यूजर का नाम
वही है डी ए एफ आर ओ एन आई एक्स
नेफ्रॉनिक्स ये इंटर अब ये कैसे में वैसे
डिसएबल कर दिया अगर आपको देखना चाहते हो
वैसे नहीं तो कैच करके भी देख सकते हो
ऑलरेडी डिसेबल्ड है अगर हम इसको अनलॉक
करना है
इसका अलग राहत है
आपको
जब भी आप क्या करते हो यूजर मोड कमल का
उसे करते हुए लोग करते तो आपका सिंगल आपको
बैंक साइन देखने को मिलेगा इसका मतलब ये
है ये लॉक हो गया अब इसको मैं क्या अनलॉक
करना है लॉक अनलॉक का मतलब डिसएबल इनेबल
करना अनलॉक करने के लिए सिंपली आपके करोगे
हिफिन यू का उसे करूंगा आईफोन एप्पल यू
चिपली अनलॉक अब आपको कैट करके दिखाऊंगा तो
ये रहा अब ये अनलॉक हो गया डिफरेंस में आप
शूट करो एक और दूसरा तरीका होता है तीसरा
अब क्या उसे करोगे पांच डी उसके बाद आईफोन
स्मॉल ल मतलब लॉक कर रहे हो कौन सा यूजर
बीएफआरएन नेफ्रॉनिक्स
पासवर्ड चेंज
करता हूं
यह देखो
सिंपली आप क्या करोगे
कम कर सकते हो आप अगर आप चाहे तो किसी भी
अकाउंट को बिल्कुल
मतलब हटाना है मतलब उसे ना कर पे वो कैसे
भी उसको सेलिना मिले तो एक दो तरीका होता
है कैसे कर सकते हो आप क्या करोगे नैनो
करो
फ्लैश एटीसी करो और फाइल ओपन करो
और सबसे लास्ट में आओ
जहां पर आपको
मिल रहा है
अगर इसको सेल ही नहीं मिलेगा तो क्या
करोगे यूजर कम ही नहीं करेगा ये जो 180
नहीं कर पाएगा अपनी मशीन में तो मैं फिर
से क्या करना ऐसे कर देता हूं तो लड़की का
कम करें क्योंकि अभी अगले क्लास में
कंट्रोल एक्स और ए ये टेंडर कॉन्सेप्ट
आपको समझ में ए गया होगा की किसी भी मशीन
कैसे होता है स्टूडियो कमांड के बड़े में
बेसिकली मैं आपको बताना चाहता था और सुडोल
फाइल थी जो मोस्ट इंपॉर्टेंट फाइल थी उसके
बड़े में बताया कैसे आप एंट्री उसमें बना
सकते हैं
आप कमेंट कीजिए हमें वहां पर लिंकडइन पर
और इसके बाद जो पासवर्ड मैनेजमेंट था वो
डिटेल एक्सप्लेन मैंने किया है और आप एक
कम आपका कम है प्रैक्टिस करना
आई बिल ट्री तू आंसर यू
तो अभी आपके लिए गवर्नमेंट है दो मिनट में
बता देता हूं मैं आपको उसमें जो कॉन्सेप्ट
रहेगा फाइल्स सिक्योरिटी रहेगा
स्टार्ट करेंगे
देखो रूट यूजर का पासवर्ड भूल गए तो क्या
होता है की एक क्लीनिक ऐसी मशीन है उसका
पासवर्ड क्या है की बाहर से आप क्या कर
सकते हो क्रैक कर सकते
हो बाहर से इसके पासवर्ड को एक्सेस कर
सकते हो रिसेट कर सकते हो बीटिंग टाइम पर
लिरिक्स में ऐसा होता है बोर्डिंग टाइम पर
कर सकते हो विंडोज में क्या होता है की
विंडोज में भी कर सकते हो विंडोज में क्या
होता है लाइव सीडी के साथ आपको करना होता
है तो विंडो का पासवर्ड भी ऐसे हो जाता है
बट लाइनेक्स में ऐसा क्या है या तो आप
क्या कर सकते हो की आप लाइव आइसो इमेज का
आपको उसे करना होगा एडरवाइज आपको क्या
करना होगा अगर ओनली पासवर्ड की प्रॉब्लम
है तो आपको बोर्डिंग टाइम पर ही आपके जो
कुछ चीज सिलेक्शन के लिए आई है ना की
एडवांस सिलेक्शन करना हो सिलेक्शन करना
वहां पर कुछ सेकंड के लिए आपको टाइम मिलता
है तो उधर ही वह चीज होती है जहां पर आपको
रूट का पासवर्ड क्या कर सकते हो
चेंज कर सकते हो
मशीन का मैं शिखा दूंगा कोई सुन नहीं है
लेकिन जब रियल एनवायरनमेंट बन जाओगे वहां
पर दो तीन टाइप की प्रोटैक्शंस होती हैं
क्योंकि उसके अंदर जान के लिए भी वहां पर
पासवर्ड सेट कर दिया जाता है
वहां पे कहानी पे आएगी सिक्योरिटी मेंटेन
की जाति है
क्योंकि अदर वाइस तो अनसिक्योर हो जाएगा
नहीं पता चला है कोई आपके फिजिकल एक्सेस
पोज गया आपकी मशीन तक और उसके बाद उसने
क्या किया लाइव शो इमेज का उसे कर आपके
रूट के पास एडमिन पासवर्ड को रिसेट कर
दिया वेरी जी वहां से हो सकता है तो इस से
बचाने के लिए वापस सिक्योरिटी होती है ओके
इस टाइप से सिक्योरिटी उधर होती है तो
वैसे ही कर सकते हैं कोई इशू नहीं है बट
वैसे आपकी मशीन में अगर वैसे लोग इन करने
से पहले आप रूट का पासवर्ड भूल गए तो उसका
कोई सॉल्यूशन नहीं है
ओके यहां पर
क्या मतलब है यहां पर रोड का मतलब भैया के
यहां पर देखो एक परसेंटेज
उसे यूजर का नाम लिख दीजिए जिसको परमीशंस
जो वह कम कर सकता है उसकी परमिशन पर उसको
कम कर सकते हैं यहां पर रूट एक ऐसा यूजर्स
है जो पूरे उसका मशीन
का मतलब क्या है की जिन फाइल से
डायरेक्टरी या जींस कमांड्स की आपको
रिटायरमेंट है एक एडमिन वाला कम करने के
लिए उसे पे परमिशन किसको है रूट को इसलिए
उसका नाम लिखा है यहां पर रूट का और वहां
पर भी आपने क्या किया ठीक है रूट जो जो कम
कर सकता है वो सारे कम करूंगा उसके बाद
कमांड में शिक्षक दाल दिया आपने की हां
इसको एक्सेस है क्या आपको की इस वाले रूट
वाले परमीशंस को आप उसे कर सकते हो बट
क्या की इन दो कमांड के लिए उसे कर सकते
हो यही दो कमांड आपको अलाउड है और बाकी
साड़ी जिला ये मतलब है यहां पर और बताइए
नेक्स्ट वन मिनट
तो ओके फिर सेशन और करते हैं और करने से
पहले फिर से आपको एक बार याद दिल देता हूं
मैं आपको या जो हमारी रिपोर्टेड सेशन
देखने वाली यूजेस है प्लीज को तू मी
लिंकडइन पेज और वहां पर जैसे ही डेट का
हमारा पेज अपडेट हो जाएगा तो प्लीज वापस
जाइए और एक मिनट का समय निकालिए और वहां
पर बताइए आप लोगों ने आज के दे में
क्या-क्या शिखा वहां पर एक पॉइंट वाइस
पॉइंट वाइस कमेंट कर दीजिए सो रेड के
लोगों को वहां पर हेल्प मिले तो ओके बाय
बाय गुड नाइट शिफ्ट इन डी नेक्स्ट क्लास
टेक केयर